Many of you don't have to be told that Donald
Trump's mental health is poor. That is cognitive
state is poor. And if you've been following
his presidency or watching this show, you
know, Trump's unstable, you know, appear that
Trump appears to be declining cognitively.
He's often confused, loses his train of thought.
His brain will glitch coinciding with these
weird shoulder spasms. It's very, very odd
and disturbing. You might suspect that the
entire coronavirus fiasco may not be improving
Donald Trump's cognitive state. And you would
be right if you've been paying attention.
This would not be a surprise because it's
been visible at press conferences. It's been
visible via the tweets.
And we have a new report out from psychiatrist
Dr. Justin Frank, who's been a guest on the
program about Donald Trump's mental health
deterioration. Now, before you jump all over
me and say David Goldwater rule, Goldwater
rule, it's unethical if somebody hasn't personally
examined Trump to evaluate his cognitive state.
Remember, the Goldwater rule was created specifically
to stop criticism about Senator Barry Goldwater
back in the 1960s. The Goldwater rule is no
objective standard. There is not a consensus
about the Goldwater rule. If applied to Trump,
the Goldwater rule would silence countless
mental health professionals from pointing
out the obvious about Donald Trump. Dr. Justin
Frank predicted that given Donald Trump's
total lack of empathy, lack of ability to
take responsibility ever, we should expect
to see Trump doing exactly what he is now
doing, shrugging off all responsibility for
the virus response, ignoring the mounting
death toll, often not even mentioning it during
his press briefings, instead talking about
ratings and popularity. Everything that Dr.
Justin Frank has been predicting and told
us on our show and that he has been observing
is coming true. Trump tweeting about his ratings
while the bodies pile up yesterday, saying,
because the ratings of my news conferences
are so high. Bachelor finale, Monday night
football type numbers. The lamestream media
is going crazy. Trump is reaching too many
people. We must stop him, said one lunatic.
Here is Trump, saying he takes no responsibility
for anything.
The Foushee said earlier this week that the
lag in testing was, in fact, a failing. Do
you take responsibility for that? And when
can you guarantee that every single American
who needs a test will be able to have a test?
What's the date of that?
Yeah, no, I don't take responsibility at all
because we were given a a set of circumstances
and we were given rules, regulations and specifications.
Dr Justin Frank believes Trump is a sociopath
having no feelings of care, concern or empathy
for other humans. Dr Justin Frank is worried
that Trump is actually unable to feel guilt
or remorse, and his public presence as president
for more than three years seems to confirm
that he doesn't seem to care about the death
toll. His mental state is deteriorating, in
part because he's unable to do his Magga rallies,
in part because everything around him is crumbling.
But it just doesn't compute with his self-perception
with how he views himself. So the daily coronavirus
briefings are kind of how Trump is getting
his fix. Given that he can't do the stadium
Magga rallies, this goes well beyond just
narcissistic personality disorder. It's more
complicated, it's more serious, but it's nothing
new. It's just far more dangerous when the
person is promoted from just doing, you know,
real estate deals in Manhattan to being president
and being responsible for the country's response
to a pandemic. It can only get worse. We are
literally in the position of trying to limit
the death precipitated by Donald Trump. This
isn't a good place to be. Dr Justin Frank
has been spot on in his analysis so far. If
we have to say, is there anything good? Trump
extended the guidelines 30 days and said,
stay the hell home. That's good. Okay. And
hopefully by the end of April, we will be
on the decline of the curve. That's the hope
remains to be seen.